you de monde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui
on se retrouve enfin pour l'épisode
numéro cinq du let's play sur max payne
3 alors on est en compagnie de gilles
alias alias voilà bon alors vous
inquiétez pas il va juste devoir en
gaule épisode en live il va par an
commenté
du coup c'était ariitea justement quand
on avait tenté de récupérer habile à la
fille du patron pour qui on bosse et on
avait fait parce que c'était trop
nombreux par rapport à nous et donc là
on passe tout de suite à ça après leur
épique fait on va voir ce qui va se
passer je pense qu'ils vont réussir à la
fois à damas
nous la hausse va à la date du 7 juin
et c'est bien car sinon il y aura bon
j'ai pas confiance en lui pas pourquoi
c'est si contrat professionnel ils ne
réussissent à matoury spécimens
projet max vraiment un fois on vous y
suit l'histoire parce que sinon c'est
pas très passionnant cinématiques mais
ses entraîneurs le style la peine où je
suis
qui
hollande était l'égal de l'homme peuvent
aller défoncer
et son serveur
c'est quoi dire là haut
l'état couvert ouvert à tous vers le
couvert
[ __ ] n'ont pas couvert
ok alors voir qu'on défonce ceux qui ont
pénétré le bureau est évidemment on va
retrouver je suppose des traces de la
fameuse d'isabella puisqu'ils viennent
de donner à chaque fois je me mets
toujours là c'est bon je me souviens à
peu près des touches y en a encore
voilà parfait
encore
ok
parce qu'il est mort quoi quoi
le mec jeu mais qu'il ne veut pas mourir
fois ça il faut beaucoup d'eux et la
tête d'un extrême à la parfait ces
montures ex surtout ce moment ça va
j'allais repenser exagéré casse dans le
jeu c'est tout seul contre 15 mike
hessman livre sur la pêche était sur lui
on se plie aux libéraux de noir et
l'offre est assez pensé mon vol était
pas manquer donc les autres filles qui
laissait toutefois qu'il est un peu
austère est lâche pas compris ce qu'ils
veulent faire enfin
blablabla
ah ça c'est joli ça
amer non en fait je recharge je fais
déjà bon soir j'attends qu'il arrive je
l'emmenais eux comment on fait pour moi
ça fait à la main nan men toi oh non
mais comment on fait pour taper à la
main je me suis même plus du tout parce
que ta pub on est forcément un truc
pareil que je mette leur mentir et la
[ __ ] de tête
comme la saison
aussi ça lui attacher une balle balle si
j'ai pas la tête je suis mort cette
dernière valse est rentré parfait s'agit
pas penser à ramasser des trucs sur
la mort non ça c'est trop bien
ça va ou quoi la niçoise
laisse-moi ramasser les balles oui voilà
parfait voilà voilà
ramassez d'autres trucs à awala parfait
comme ça j'ai le guen aussi ok nickel
c'est quand même un peu dur on rentre
dans le temps ah merde j'ai zappé
experts
c'est parti sur des noirs
ah ok
alors ça va arriver de la droite ou de
la gauche attention ne peut pas faire
par ici der merwe sur internet ah oui
j'ai juste à temps
ah j'allais oublier cette bonne grosse
sensation du la times ok colas a annoncé
que ces dernières années je me suis fait
tellement longtemps
inutile mais jamais de la viande issue
et sociales igas
à dacca style à faire
non non non ça soit ça à merde non pas
ça non plus
[ __ ]
c'est comme ça c'est la vie de la gauche
on a eu le premier promu mesure qu'est
ce que tu veux faire
c'est pas bon ainsi sa monnaie
e
un yes j'ai une 6ème aberration sans le
dire
ok ils sont vraiment beaucoup non mais
sincèrement c'est même plus mal
ces machines peuvent aller bâtard sac à
merde moi j'ai pas de grenade mois
quoique
pas mal
allez merde [ __ ] ça sent pas bon
ah oui aux pièces bâtard
bien attendre l'entrée de stratégie
non vous
c'est bon alors là ça va faire le plein
de munitions
ouais niveau réaliste quand même max
payne va pas se mentir
voilà corps brûlé ou l'autre we you le
tofu il était la voix off alors démarrer
ce système est bâti
dépêche toi je dois tout fut assassiné
maps multijoueurs
j'analyse ce que je pouvais rentrer des
rivages côtiers à l'or mondial
on va regarder dans le décor j'ai reçus
m'ont pas fait gaffe j'ai dû louper des
antalgiques comme d'habitude
comme à mon habitude papa sidec
surveillons blanc non un grave mais
c'est de rester vivant 7e demain
c'est ce que j'ai vu c'est pourquoi lui
ne restent pas mari était avec eux et
qui fait sortir je vais être obligé de
casser les trucs non ta g du loup pas un
truc magique là dedans fais-toi la 11e à
la parfait c'est sûr
pas d'autres j'aimerais bien parce qu'on
n'a plus que 2 g + de vie c'est quoi ça
un morceau d'armand nord bat parfait en
plus celle qu'on a là maintien